[Musique]
vague de démission et de rupture
conventionnelle difficulté de
recrutement qu'en est-il réellement sur
le terrain à la roumiac donjon bonjour
c'est le président de Manpower France
alors ce phénomène de grande démission
comme on l'appelle aux États-Unis ce
qu'il est en train oui ou non de se
propager en France parce qu'on a un
nombre de démission qui est au plus haut
depuis 2008 et en même temps un taux
d'émission qui est moins de 3%. voilà
alors nous comment vous appréciez ça sur
le terrain alors nous nous avons plutôt
ça le grand basculement c'est-à-dire que
cette notion de démission aux Etats-Unis
elle s'est aussi traduit par le fait
qu'il y a des millions de personnes qui
ont quitté le marché du travail ce qu'on
ne voit pas en France qu'on voit pas en
Europe par contre il y a deux phénomènes
qui aujourd'hui viennent se percuter le
premier c'est qu'il y a une demande très
forte sur le marché de l'emploi de la
part des entreprises et dans le deuxième
temps les attentes des candidats les
attentes des employés ont beaucoup
évolué et ce qu'il faut c'est que les
deux réussissent à se rencontrer donc il
y a pas de vagues de démission en série
pour vous on est face à des épices
phénomènes ou même peut-être certains
secteurs sont plus concernés que
d'autres alors on est au même niveau à
peu près de démission que en 2007 donc
alors bien évidemment très supérieurs à
ce que nous avons vécu ces trois quatre
dernières années puis après est-ce que
la démission est-ce que c'est la
démission qui crée la pénurie de
l'emploi ou est-ce que c'est parce que
comme il y a une très forte demande les
entreprises se prennent des personnes
les unes les unes les autres et donc ça
crée de la démission c'est vrai le vrai
sujet mais
il quittent leur job pourquoi pour
changer de voix on pourrait rester dans
le même secteur c'est quoi quel est
l'objectif d'un meilleur salaire
sûrement on imagine aussi faire un jump
comme on dit alors je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le cas il y a
plusieurs phénomènes d'abord le premier
c'est qu'il y a des gens qui changent
d'environnement le covid a été un
révélateur pour eux ils changent
d'environnement c'est soit de métier et
souvent pour un métier qu'il qualifie de
moins pénible et on a vu beaucoup de
gens par exemple partir de l'hôtellerie
de la restauration où il change
d'environnement il va être plus près de
chez eux ils veulent partir donc
par exemple en région mais partir à la
campagne et puis vous avez ceux qui dans
le même secteur comme il y a une demande
qui est très forte il reste dans le même
secteur mais des fois aussi pour se
rapprocher de chez eux ou parce que ils
ont l'opportunité d'augmenter leur
salaire de façon relativement
significative on a bien ces deux
phénomènes qui aujourd'hui sont à
l'oeuvre et qui perturbe le marché de
l'emploi et donc c'est salarié qui est
démissionne retrouvent facilement au
globale un emploi aujourd'hui c'est la
bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui les gens qui
ont une compétence qui est attendue par
le marché on peut de difficultés à
trouver un emploi après ça dépend bien
évidemment du bassin d'emploi sur lequel
ils sont situés et c'est vrai qu'avec 7%
de chômage on commence à avoir la plus
grande partie des gens qui sont
facilement employables et dans une
économie bien évidemment où les
compétences sont différentes aujourd'hui
de ce que c'était demain avec hier
pardon avec de plus en plus de numérique
donc les 7% de demandeurs doit souvent
il faut les accompagner pour qu'il
retrouve un emploi soit il faut qu'on
les forme soit il faut qu'on les
accompagne pour lever un certain nombre
d'inhibiteurs qui les empêchent de
pouvoir accès à l'emploi par exemple de
la guerre garde d'enfants de la mobilité
ou des problèmes de santé parmi ceux qui
démissionnent celles et ceux qui
démissionnent il y a aussi parfois des
durable par rapport aux horaires de
travail aux rémunérations à l'ambiance
dans le cadre du travail aux horaires
encore une fois justement on a fait donc
une étude sociologique que sur le besoin
de comprendre ce que sont que les
attentes des candidats ne seraient soit
cadre ou pas cadre ou encore une fois
absolument c'est dans les services donc
on a fait cette étude pour essayer de
mieux comprendre ce que les attentes
sociologiques et là aujourd'hui il y a
plusieurs la une que j'ai déjà cité
c'est que les gens veulent des jobs qui
sont qui considèrent comme étant moins
pénibles et sur lequel d'ailleurs ils
ont une meilleure équilibre entre leur
vie privée et leur vie professionnelle
typiquement là encore les métiers de
l'autre et des restauration ou pendant
le covid beaucoup de gens ont découvert
que Ben s'occuper de sa famille c'était
aussi important et que ils veulent avoir
quelque part plus de temps pour eux ils
veulent aussi qu'on fasse plus attention
à eux qu'on leur parle mieux que et que
on soit attentif à ce que sont leurs
demandes ils sont attentifs aussi vous
le signaliez à l'ambiance dans laquelle
ils vivent et puis ils veulent être
fiers de l'entreprise dans laquelle ils
travaillent en particulier aujourd'hui
il va être fier de l'engagement en
particulier climatique de l'entreprise
dans laquelle ils sont donc c'est
l'ensemble de ces éléments qui ont
beaucoup évolué sur ces deux ou trois
dernières années et sur lesquelles les
entreprises doivent être capables de
répondre si elles veulent capables et
qu'elle va d'attirer des candidats et de
garder et de les garder pour éviter la
démission un aramia qui a pas crédits il
y a aussi les ruptures conventionnelles
qu'il a aussi sont au plus haut
qu'est-ce qu'on constate sur le terrain
est-ce qu'il y a une augmentation
inédite des ruptures qu'est-ce que ça
signifie ce que c'est à l'initiative du
salarié de l'employeur
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est quand
même majoritairement sur un marché de
candidats c'est le candidat qui a plutôt
la main et donc vous pouvez avoir des
gens qui ont justement envie de changer
d'environnement et je pense en
particulier à ceux qui veulent changer
par exemple de région et qui disent bon
ben voilà je veux quitter
l'environnement dans lequel je suis j'ai
envie de partir ailleurs et j'aimerais
qu'on trouve j'ai un accord pour que je
sois capable de partir donc
effectivement ça vient signifier que il
y a un certain nombre de personnes qui
se sentent plus bien dans
l'environnement dans lequel elle se
situe je pense aujourd'hui c'est
majoritairement à la demande j'avais des
salariés parce que là encore c'est les
candidats qui ont plutôt la main alors
que on était plutôt dans un
environnement où les entreprises
allaient plutôt bien elles ont des
difficultés elles-mêmes à trouver des
candidats donc c'est peu elle ça peut
arriver bien évidemment qui sont à la
menace c'est plutôt les candidats si on
prend la hauteur encore une fois tout ça
concerne un client on parle des cadres
des salariés moins qualifiés qui veulent
des meilleures conditions de travail on
a évoqué là alors c'était déjà très vrai
pour les cadres c'est encore plus vrai
pour les cadres c'est plus nouveau on va
dire pour les salariés les employés les
ouvriers et je suis je suis marqué par
les discussions que je peux avoir avec
un certain nombre de clients qui me
disent que ils ont des personnes qui
jusqu'à présent étaient contente d'avoir
un job stable qui partent ou vous avez
sans doute aussi noté qui a eu une
augmentation très sensible des arrêts de
travail donc il y a marqué le fait que
les gens sont pas très heureux souvent
dans un certain nombre de cas dans leur
dans leur environnement et ces gens-là
disent l'environnement dans lequel je
suis ne me plait plus j'ai un
contremaître j'ai un chef qui fait plus
suffisamment attention à moi qui me
parle pas de façon respectueuse et donc
et donc qui partent et ça je dirais
c'est quelque chose d'un peu plus
nouveau là encore c'est sans doute lié
au fait que le marché du travail et est
très fort mais aussi c'est une vraie
évolution sociologique et sur laquelle
les entreprises doivent s'adapter et
surtout c'est l'ensemble de l'entreprise
qui doit s'adapter parce que quand je
rencontre des directions des Directeurs
de Ressources Humaines des directeurs
ils le comprennent bien et souvent ils
disent mais comment est-ce que je peux
aider mon management à comprendre que le
monde a changé qu'il faut traiter et
travailler avec les employés de façon
différente pour qu'on soit capable de
garder parce que aujourd'hui on a une
vraie vague de démission et chez des
gens sur lesquels jusqu'à présent on
avait une grande stabilité Alain il y a
un autre phénomène qui nous vient des
États-Unis aussi c'est le courrier de
quitting c'est la démission silencieuse
parce que tout le monde n'a pas le
courage et bien évidemment de tout
plaquer donc en gros on lève le pied
sans se faire virer on fait le job et
juste le job on refuse les heures sup
toutes les missions qui sont pas dans le
périmètre du poste est-ce que vous aussi
sur le terrain vous avez constaté ce
phénomène et si oui comment vous
l'analysez je pense que d'abord il était
déjà avant vous savez il y avait des
gens qui
écrivaient des livres sur les bullshits
Jobs donc un certain nombre de Jobs qui
dépassent toujours très intéressants et
sur lesquels les gens restaient quand
même donc pour revenir sur sur ce sujet
là c'est clair que de plus en plus les
gens ont besoin de sens dans ce qu'ils
font
et ces raisons de citer que derrière
quand il ne trouve pas le sens soit ils
prennent la décision de partir soit ils
disent bon ben j'ai pas de sens bon je
fais le juste minimum donc c'est là
encore des enjeux pour les entreprises
de faire en sorte de donner du sens aux
gens de bien leur expliquer en quoi
est-ce que leur travail était important
est intéressant faire en sorte aussi
qu'ils aient le sentiment qu'on
s'intéresse à eux qu'on s'intéresse à ce
qu'ils vont faire après sans doute qu'on
est aussi avec des gens qui s'ennuient
un peu plus
plus rapidement que le passé donc il
faut les faire tourner sur des jobs de
façon plus importante donc les solutions
existent simplement il faut comprendre
l'environnement dans lequel on est et
s'assurer qu'on bâtit un environnement
et pour revenir sur ce sujet là où les
gens ont vraiment le sentiment qui a du
sens dans ce qui est dans ce qu'ils font
et y faire très attention merci Alain
donc le président
[Musique]